5 45 on your monday morning what's  driving you crazy well you know that  future train project down to southern  california  it's derailing a lane of traffic on i-15  this week  talking about that express west it's  part of surveying for the project in the  right shoulder in the right lane of the  southbound 15 going to be closed  all the way from warm springs for about  12 miles to around the seven magic  mountains painted rock sculptures  nevada department of transportation says  the closures will run  every single night this week from 9 00  p.m until  five each following morning now we'll  remind you about this during our regular  traffic ports but we just  kind of wanted to give you the heads up  on that one in the meantime please  buckle up  drive carefully and put down that phone  if there is something driving you crazy  go ahead and email me and  send video send pictures to traffic  eight at eightnewsnow.com